something philosophical and weird how
about you
let's go let's go sci-fi movie you go
we'll go back and forth i'll go step by
step
so there there's an m-class planet okay
i know what that means
it's because that's you played this [ __ ]
in that one no no no no no no no
it's a planet that like can um
much like our planet it has a you know
we have
um an atmosphere oxygen you know i mean
and
life can live on it water right and what
happens is
there's a meteor right that um
lands hundreds of you got land not on
earth but a m-class
planet like earth right lands on it and
in this media there is like some sort of
like um
biological um thing in it that mutates
the animals that are on and humans that
are on
the planet right but what happens is the
the the humanoids right they they
realize that these creatures are
happening so they create
different like areas where they build
the walls
right because other things that mutated
so there's you know
on this planet there's like societies
living in
walls right but they right but there's
this one
you know i mean group of people that are
living in this thing they're running out
of resources
and they found out about another you
know i mean settlement but they have to
go through
what you're pulling from next-gen
no i'm not this is not a next-gen the
next generation
inspired no it's not right
there's no [ __ ] next generation
that's episode 308
let me finish okay what can you don't
like it
let me finish i'm making it up right so
it's like
so imagine and this is not hundreds of
years people living in these
you know in these groups right i'm in
these walls
right imagine a big circle of wall
people living in it you know okay and
then they know that there are other
you know i mean you know i mean places
right that they have um
other societies that have created where
they block out so there's
these gigantic gaps through forests and
through planes
where it's like these mutated humans and
mutated animals and stuff like that
and there's this one group right of like
a city
right that they're running out of
resources they need to get to the
but they've never been beyond the wall
so no one's seen each other
yeah no one's ever seen each other so
they don't even know
this is just the rumor and hearsay right
so a group of kids
decide that what you gave me eight
seconds to pitch my idea
about the four-parted man
i'm done now i'm not done yet i know
that's why i'm telling you i only got
eight seconds
and you're like five minutes in can i
paper towel yeah
sure my armpits are sweating from this
but what they realized was they think
that the only the animals were mutated
right but they there are actually
humanoids right
that have mutated that have a higher
intelligence
but they're like they're like mutated by
you know alien you know i mean
dna right and stuff that was in the
meteor that [ __ ] everything
up mm-hmm nice don't you're being
sarcastic no
meteor you gotta justify it don't be
like that man
i was gonna pull in a writer's room okay
i know i'm just throwing it out there
right
so this group of kids teenagers you mean
let's cast a variety of look different
people
well hell no you're not a casting
director you're in a writer's room
yeah i'm writing the characters i can
say that i can say that one of them's
samoan
yeah alfalfi i love that alfalfa and his
sister samoan
is his daughter not his sister's little
sister right
she's he's kind of a big guy right and
she's like um younger she's like 12 and
little
right uh punji is a part of it
punji is um american don't say it
no punji is i want to give
some friend people that need help you
know what i mean
that fan right um he's blind
right and then can he's talk and then we
gotta put a white in it because you know
what i mean
he's got to put white people in it yeah
you got to yeah the um
smith family father yeah
it's almost racist if you don't put any
white people in because these are
humanoids and if you're saying
humanoids when they come in or not
minority colors then it's [ __ ] weird
it's all asians
are all humanoid anyway they um i'll
forget it then
they go on this track to you know i mean
and they they go on an adventure
i want to tell me your movie i want to
hear you pitch that to gene
you didn't no you know what i liked
about this is i thought i just made it
up no but i thought you were taking it
the route
here can i give you a [ __ ] story i
want to pitch the village route i think
you're going the village route
with it like they think there's other
things out there and they go on they're
like
there's nothing or like like it's like
modern day times
they think it's like post-apocalyptic
you know what i mean
so they built this city yeah right
on this wall right and they just
they go to the other like they're
they're told like hey there's so they
leave the wall
and then they realize oh [ __ ] there's a
starbucks it's like yeah
so nothing happened no so these elders
lied to keep them george the village
meets planet of the apes
and there we go right you want to hear
my ridge
you want to hear my ridge idea of my
prison musical
oh this is i want to hear it's the
musical go ahead
so i've always had this idea of of
writing a prison musical
set in the philippines and it centers
around
a um uh because you know we have a very
big
county on one second you're already not
you're not i'll tell you why
what was your thought process because
number one yeah and
be honest with me yeah